Film Courage: Wendy when did you begin LA4hire? Wendy Kram, Owner/Operator of Wendy's LA4hire:
began la for hiring mm to eat and it was
I was thinking of at the time moving
back to New York where I'm from and I
was having drinks with the girlfriend
who works in media and she said you know
what it's 2008 the bank said I'll crash
nobody was hiring and everyone was
cutting back and she said you know you
should do consulting you're kind of like
you're like la for hire you know you
know you've been in the business for
working in studios Disney's Sony
universal you know the player is you
know how to navigate I think you'd be a
very valuable resource for people
outside of you know the business and
we're looking for connections and to
package projects and so on and it's like
that sounds good and I was taking a
subway to where I was staying and by the
time I got up out of the subway I had a
I was thought okay I'm starting a
company called LA for hire consulting
and I envisioned my logo and I started
brainstorming about the services that I
would offer and that's how I started
this was a subway in LA Oh in New York
you're taking the LA metro yeah so what
was your first step in starting it my
first step was talking to industry
colleagues and saying what do you think
of this idea the notion was for
production companies or producers who
might be you know not with studios and
had material looking to you how do you
or if you're a screenwriter how do you
get an agent how do you get if you don't
know people how can you get your
material seen the fur production
companies that might be having cutbacks
that they could hire freelance executive
someone who knows the players who knows
how do you understand script development
who kids confident when it comes to
working with writers and helping
implement notes if there's open writing
assignments contacting the agents
telling them the nature of the project
is discussing preparing writers list
directors lists and so it really be a
conduit for companies that might not be
based in LA and might not have those
relationships I think you'd said in
another interview that you know you'll
have people come up to you on set when
you're working with one client and say
you know what Wendy I like what you're
doing I'm I do this and I don't you know
have a script but I normally am you know
a grip or something can you help me what
are some of the things that people
normally have trouble with that aren't
used to being sort of in the development
part right well I think the first thing
is really knowing and understanding what
a good script is a lot of people will
write a script and they may go through a
couple of drafts and I think that they
they don't have a full understanding or
appreciation of what it really takes for
an executive to decide that they want to
recommend it to their boss for producer
to option material first studio to
decide to finance it and a lot of times
there are really great ideas with
stories at the end of the day it's is it
well executed it can there have been
times for myself as a producer where
I've heard a concept and I say oh my god
this sounds amazing I want to option it
then I read the script
and the characters are not particularly
well-developed
the dialogue might be very what we often
people will hear comment among
executives it's on the nose or it's
expositional and it just then requires
too much development to get it to a
place where it needs to be that it winds
up being a pass now
unless it's based on source material
such as a graphic novel a book an
article and sometimes you can use that
to sell a project without a script but
it used to be for the tongue that I
started in developed
about 20 years ago dating myself it was
easy to sell log lines I it would there
was just much more financing of
development and because of the economic
changes the studios are not financing
development at all the way they used to
is that post 2008 or even even the post
2008 yeah yeah I think you said to in an
article yeah I know you've written a lot
of fantastic articles on is it script
magazine skirt magazines then writer's
digest
writer's digest okay great so do
excellent sites about how there's
different skill sets for above the line
versus below the line and they're both
equally important but can we just define
what some of those skill sets are sure
so above the line which is what I've
been involved with is finding the
material so whether it's optioning a
true story life rights book original
script and then getting it ready to
start making submissions identifying who
the right buyers are understanding the
market knowing that Netflix and HBO and
Showtime buy certain kinds of projects
worth where as NBC ABC CBS have
different mandates and the and same with
future companies like Fox Searchlight is
more akin to independent movies whereas
if you look at most of the studios doing
they're doing tentpole movies or
franchise films you look at Disney where
they're primarily doing you know Star
Wars the Marvel Universe and their own
IP or crown jewels the classic fairy
tales and the so the above the line is
taking the material and identifying the
right home the right buyers attaching
directors actors
and assembling your crew the
below-the-line are the nuts and bolts
people who make the movie happen people
with you know the skills so whether it's
your boom operator editor a cinema
photographer and they have a completely
different skill set which I I mean when
I look at great Sena photographers or
any cinema photographer I'm amazed at
how it really involves engineering and
artistry and it's beyond my
comprehension really how they do it
so there's yeah different skill sets so
we always hear every good entrepreneur
always ask the question to themselves
what need am i filling a marketplace so
with LA for hire when you had that sort
of epiphany moment on the subway what
what were you thinking the need is that
you're feeling the deep definitely was I
found myself when I was a development
executive I'd been started out as a
creative executive for a producer at
Disney and then I worked at sand dollar
which I felt very fortunate to work
there was one of the biggest management
companies in Hollywood and we had deals
at Universal and Disney and I always
loved working with writers and their
different executives that have different
strengths and I found that working with
writers and helping them bring out their
best work was constantly feedback that I
would get from the writers I was working
with and just loved that process so much
and then when I was on my own in between
jobs and my friend had suggested why
don't you do consulting and as it was I
I kept getting people coming to me for
advice with their scripts and how to
make it better and so I just decided all
right well let me turn this into a you
know a real business and the other need
was definitely when I looked at
companies producers filmmakers all over
the world that like I had a friend who
was a producer in Germany and he spoke
English fluently and he asked me for
help on a project where he said I need
to know how to talk to the agents and it
wasn't that he didn't speak English his
English was perfect he said he felt like
he didn't know the right way to pitch
things that kind of buzz words and so on
- you get taken seriously and so on so
that's another thing I do it my company
I coach your emerging filmmakers or you
can even be perfect existing
professionals how to improve the the way
they present their material and I also
noticed many times that right on my
pitch an idea and it doesn't sound that
interesting so I'll start asking
questions and as I start to pull out
more information I go ah and then we put
a different spin on it that can convey
the idea more strongly so a lot of times
I feel that writers can undersell their
property they don't have the right kind
of spin to communicate this is another
thing writers because they live with
their characters have lived with their
characters for years and you know in the
process of writing months they know
their characters so well that there
sometimes is the unconscious feeling
that when they're writing something on
the page or giving a logline that we're
going to know all the you know the the
the the dots between are those the
connections between the dots so I think
it's an important process for
writer producer to be able to find the
best way to articulate their concept
obviously but because they might have a
great idea in it they might not be
communicating in the best way possible
the other thing is with companies let's
say in Europe is understanding who are
the good names that really trigger
movies in terms of yeah actors is a lot
of times people mention names and they
don't necessarily even if it's a
wonderful actor who's well respected
they might not trigger the sale it might
not be a name that's meaningful to a
Netflix or or is a Fox Searchlight and
so on so that's one of the things that I
will know and the only reason why I will
know is because I'm in constant contact
on a daily basis with people who know a
lot more than me so it's not that I'm so
you know brilliant or you know that it's
rocket science but it's being able to
have access I feel like every day I'm
always learning more from people who are
more in the note than I am it's
interesting what you say about
communication I know this is a little
bit of a tangent I'm going off on but I
just read an article about managers and
ones with high IQ versus ones with maybe
more of a normal IQ yeah and how the
ones with a high IQ actually were more
off-putting and they didn't realize that
about themselves hmm so it sounds like
with sometimes just the communication
and it's not it's not maybe that they
were even coming across as will I know
more it was just their communication
style it was different and so people
couldn't relate to it so it sounds like
- is writers because they're so internal
they don't rave you
they just need ya just how does a little
bit of an objective you know point of
view because it is very internal you're
living it's and I know for myself when
I'm working I also manage a few select
writers and when I'm working with them
they'll often say okay I need a fresh
set of eyes and if I've gone through
multiple drafts I'll get to a point
where I'll say that you know I want to
give it show this to an industry
colleague or let's you know get a reader
who I trust and let's get their their
thoughts I think we all needed a certain
point an objective set of eyes to look
at material and the balance of course is
being able to do that
without losing yourself and your core
vision and I think one of the things you
and I had talked about was the notion of
if like you're looking for a mentor is
it good to have someone give critique of
your project or not I say absolutely but
it should be a respected professional or
someone whose opinion you really respect
it can be a friend who's quite
intelligent or has a good sense of story
but the you know definitely don't
protect yourself by not asking someone
who may not have your best interests at
heart and would just criticize to be
critical sure sure and I actually want
to ask you more about that later in
terms of also to someone that might be
too nice because they don't want to hurt
your feelings right but it ends up
hurting you in the end just real quickly
Wendy I mean I know why I love watching
writer q and A's I find writers
fascinating what is it about writers
that interest you so much oh goodness I
would say maybe from the time I was a
child I just loved stories as a way of
immersing ourselves into another world I
think also any Penton problems we as
human beings have or children when you
see another character going through
something difficult there's an empathic
connection that you make and that you
can vicariously experience what they're
going through a lot of times I think it
can be therapeutic and healing and I
think that is the magic of great films
as well as great literature there's it's
connecting to the the universal themes
or what I mean Carl Jung talks about the
collective unconscious and that and I
know there when a lot of people will
will speak about the importance of films
that you can reach such a huge audience
that ranges you know ethnic cultural
socio-economic a great case in point I
have many favorite movies I don't want
to isolate this as my favorite of all
time but one of my favorite movies I
felt was so powerful was a wrestler and
I said okay what does a upper-middle
class you know young woman from New York
have in common with a wrestler I don't
even watch the sport nothing but that
character's plight the way he was an
outsider the way he had regrets the way
he wanted to fix some part of his past
and mend his relationship with his with
his daughter was just so moving and so
powerful I mean I found myself at the
end of the movie crying so I love that
about movies and I love that writers can
create whether it's Aaron Sorkin he's
such a master of dialogue - Guillermo
del Toro who can create such an
extraordinary immersive world it's just
the magic of storytelling oh and I'd say
we do really being able to if I carry
ously experience someone else
I love the wrestler I want to watch that
night you reimburses does I want to rent
it again yeah how does a writer know
that their screenplay is ready for
market
is a very good question I think the
first thing it's just really essential
that a writer submitted to colleagues
for feedback and I mean I am a
professional in this field a lot of
times I even though I am NOT a writer I
write treatments I work with writers on
treatments and Bibles and so on and at a
certain point I'll go through multiple
drafts I have a good built-in sense of
editing but at a certain point you know
I might think
this is great and then I'll send it to a
trusted colleague whether it's another
executive at a production company or a
writer whose opinion I respect and
they'll come back and I don't know if
they'll look money in my ass if I
couldn't say that but they'll come back
with feedback and go you know the the
treatment really isn't getting
interesting until page tip so I would
cut out the first page in a half and you
know what it's so and it it's it makes
it better
and there are so I think are times where
if it's someone who is opinion you know
you need to really stay centered and on
point and I was something they
definitely feel strongly about for
writers is that especially in the notes
taking process because let's say a
writer sets up a project with a
production company studio or network and
they give notes one of the worst things
to do is to constantly be defending your
position and producers and executives
will start to feel you know what life's
too short this person isn't receptive
they're not fun to work with they're not
getting it they love it everything
they're doing you know what I'm not
going to renew or we're going to replace
the writer the best way for a writer to
be able to take notes is to be totally
open and receptive and to try to hear
like what almost like with a second
sense of what the executive is trying to
say so let's say they say let me just
think of an example that I don't think a
character should you know say this line
they sound kind of mean right here and I
don't feel and then the writer if you're
listening rather than just defending it
you say oh that wasn't my attention I
was i meant that he was being defensive
and a little bit sarcastic but he was
kind of trying to be say it in a
charming way so then the executive would
say okay
I get it now but that wasn't coming
through so then the writer can see that
their intention wasn't coming across it
that they would go back and tweak it a
bit so again I think it's very important
to stay like you know true to your voice
and not just like roll over if someone
says okay well we have a an 85 year old
protagonist um and she has dementia but
I decided that I like everything else
about this story but let's turn her into
a thirteen year old now
and believe it or not I have heard of
situations not too far away from that as
a writer I think you need to defend your
position and why it was essential to the
story that that character is was 85 with
dementia that might not be the best
example but it's basically a balance
between maintaining the integrity of
your vision because you can't just roll
over for everything because then you
wind up with nothing
and you compromise artistry and any kind
of creative vision that you have but
anyway in terms of a writer knowing when
a project is ready I think that I hear a
lot of writers when I'm working with
them they'll say well there's always
going to be improvements to be made I
think when you are working with people
whether it's a strong script consultant
development executive friend who's maybe
a writer whose opinion you respect
development executive assistant to a
producer assistant to a writer director
and so on someone who's really
experienced with reading material and
knowing what Studios want that when it
gets to a point where there's less and
less notes and the collective feeling is
yeah there might be some work that still
needs to be done because there always
will be but it's good enough and for me
the bar of what's good enough is the
character that's that's a well-developed
that's really coming through even if
there may be irascible or somewhat
unlikable that they we still can have
empathy for that character if they're a
villain it's still good to have some
empathy not always as important but for
your protagonist there's been a
distinction between sympathy what they
might do doesn't have to be sympathetic
but you should have a degree of empathy
for them and so I think it's it's really
when you're when the feedback comes back
pretty consistently that this is good
and you're not just looking for your
validation you have to be you know
really open
I almost picture it like the kid in the
class that finishes the test before
everybody else and walks out and
everybody looks around like wow how'd
they finish that so fast can we take
that same analogy with a new writer who
kind of says you know what I just want
to get my work out there I don't really
need all these drafts I know this is
good right you know it's possible
someone might be a savant of
screenwriting and able to do it
every great screenwriter that I've seen
and the ones who get the all the awards
they always say that it's taken them 30
40 drafts there is a top top one of the
most powerful show runners and telev in
hit television history and she said and
this might be an obvious thing to say
but she said you know a lot of people
say they want my life but they're not
willing to put in the hours and the
blood sweat and tears I have another
friend who's a top female showrunner and
I know that hours that she works and
it's not a 40-hour week sometimes it's
an 80 hour week she's there's she loves
her job
and she on weekends sometimes she'll be
there till midnight on a Friday and
Saturday working you know eight to 12
hours and then the weekdays so
the I think you know look Mozart I think
wrote his you know Compton amazing
compositions and he was somewhat of a
savant so I think it is possible but I
think something that gets in the way is
I understand the enthusiasm and
excitement to want to get your script
out there but there can be may be either
naivete or hubris and I've noticed a lot
there are times when the writers are
more and it could be the same with an
actor that they're more focused on the
end result and I know for me as the
producer and executive I'm focused on
the end result there's nothing I want
more than a movie to get made it is the
greatest high after you've gone through
all this work and seeing it come to
fruition and seeing the set designer
create the sets and your actors you know
actually performing the lines and the
scenes but if you look at every
wonderful writer director filmmaker
actor the trajectory of their careers
they started out like doing little bit
parts and movies that you never would
have thought they would wind up one day
getting an Oscar so it's at each step is
a is a part of the process of the
journey
he's just say whether they get someone
like Kathryn Bigelow you know when she
started out or patty Jenkins for example
when Cuddy did monster and I think she'd
gone to AFI she just kept doing good
work these are people just kept doing
good work I don't think that you know
patty Jenkins thought when she was at
AFI oh I'm gonna do an indie film called
monster and get an Oscar for the leading
actress and I'm then gonna go and do
Wonder Woman superhero and be the first
woman to woman to you know break all box
office records as the director
barry jenkins when he did moonlight i
don't think he was doing it because he
thought oh I'm gonna get an Oscar I
think he wanted to he was compelled to
tell a story and he told it beautifully
and it affected and resonated you know
with so many people so I think the most
important thing for writers directors
actors is to stay committed to the craft
and just doing the best work that you
can and surround yourself with people
who can give you really constructive
feedback even if it's not always what
you want to hear but to be open to
feedback that can be constructive and
make you a better writer do you think
that's a factor of age do you think
younger people really want to rush to it
or it's not about that it could vary in
my experience it's not about that
because I know older writers who you
know they filmed like times not on their
side so that they actually in some ways
can be in more of a rush than younger
writers that's true yeah when you see a
writer that you know that they do have
talent you can see that it just maybe
needs a little more refining and you
need to slow them down what are some of
the things that you do
first I don't like to ever feel that I'm
in the position to like slow so I went
down most of what I do is just ask
questions if in the script there are
there's a plot aspects or character
behavior that's not clear to me or
confusing or inconsistent I'll just ask
the question and I always tell the
writer that they never do feel compelled
to agree with me it's not a dictatorial
thing but it is for the purpose of I
feel I'm a pretty good barometer of what
other how other executives are are going
to respond to material and if it's not
clear to me then there's a good chance
that it might not be clear to someone
else so they don't have to I never feel
like I want to impose something to be
done a certain way but I will raise a
question or I'll say I feel that this
dialogue it
and feel authentic to me it feels like
there's an agenda the writer has an
agenda that you want the character to
say this but I think if we're really
looking in the scene and a daughter is
responding to her mother how much she
really respond and I'll ask the writer
to go back and kind of try and find the
truth rather than the written agenda if
that makes sense so so I think it's
really more about asking questions and
pointing out areas that can be improved
rather than slow down I'm like if you
think it's ready to go and you're happy
with and you don't agree then by all
means you should pursue that but I think
a lot of times there can be a tendency
to take something out too hastily
do you think people are aware of that
how damaging that can be because if they
get consistent coverage it just kind of
like labels that one project or even
their name it's not ready you're yeah
and I'm getting let's say oh yeah
because here's the thing is so you have
a lot of people writers will be focused
on networking which is great networking
is important let's say you meet someone
it's a producer and they say quit send
me your script and it's not very good
you have a frozen moment in time to have
that capture that person's attention and
if they don't respond to it or they have
an assistant who reads it and says
because a lot of times it is what
happens and says it wasn't very good the
next time you want to get something in
they might not be as inclined to read
your work you know tell them it's the
past we the the writing was just not up
to snuff it was very amateurish the
person doesn't even know how to write a
script to be honest there are certain
things that there is classic formatting
but there's also certain telltale signs
such as if there's dialogue on the page
that takes up half a page or almost the
whole page that's a telltale sign of
with exception of course there are
always exceptions
but that would be a sign that it's an
amateur if there's peaches in a script
that are so dense that it looks like a
novel that would be another sign if
there's like page after page of in very
dense descriptions that will wind up in
and they recycled in or the trash in the
your computer so let's suppose I'm at a
networking event or I get invited to a
great festival and it's a mixer so
someone says hey so you write let may I
see your work and I know it's probably
not ready what's the best way to let
them know that we're I'm not hurting
their feelings really sure it's a great
question I would say that oh that's
fantastic
can I get your card I'm I'm doing
revisions and I'd love to send it to you
when it's ready oh so just like I drop
you and you know can I drop you an email
as a reminder when it's ready sure
that'd be great
oh great so you're not waiting a year
for the revision you're keeping them in
your mind or in their mind sorry you're
saying hi I met you you know and thanks
sadly and you know what it could be a
year if that's if that's really what it
takes to me it's ready when it's ready
so an Eevee I met you a year ago at the
at Sundance and I mentioned a sci-fi
one-hour trauma that I have and I
finally have it ready and it's been
vetted and actually I don't even know if
I would go into all that detail but it
said I mean and here's the brief premise
the very very briefly executives don't
want a whole big description because
they also can be liable they don't want
to hear ideas in too much detail because
they're not allowed to accept them for
legal reasons but if it's someone that
you have met and just to give them a
refresher this is the sci-fi one-hour
pilot about an alien who comes to earth
can I send it to you and they'll either
respond and say great or they might say
no that also there's another
subject which is submission release
forms because a lot of executives and
agents will not take material without a
submission release form unless it's
being if it's this is if it's not being
submitted by an agent or manager
interesting yeah I wonder if people
really understand that when people see
and I've seen it on Twitter people's
Twitter BIOS do I do not take you know
and I see it all the time so and I for a
newbie I do think they realize the
implications and how it's a turn-off to
when someone says no like that there's
reasons why right it's not because they
are they they don't think your idea is
good it's because they're protecting
them so right so then there are ways
around to try and bypassed that and yeah
that would probably fall under a whole
conversation there's a networking and
Submission policies oops but for someone
to respect that when they see that
someone says we do not take line
positions okay yeah well a good counter
can be okay I'd be happy to sign a
submission release form and as I say
that my you know disclaimer is that as
I'm saying this I am NOT an
entertainment attorney sure so whoever
you may be listening if you get a
submission release form you advise you
to show it to an entertainment attorney
and it is up to you to decide whether to
sign it or not but that is a way around
that legality of them not wanting to
accept it at all I saw you write
something about dull bits in a script
and I'm curious what that means yes a
Hitchcock has one of my favorite quotes
which and not let's see if I for all of
those who are Hitchcock aficionados
forgive me if I don't have it exactly
right but it's something to the effect
of movies are exactly like a real life
but with all the dull bits cut out and
essentially if you think about films you
are lying
movies are lies so let's say you're
doing a story about Helen Keller
or Abraham Lincoln and let's say this
ban whether it takes place over a year
or takes place over a lifetime or 20
years we're seeing a two-hour movie
generally speaking an hour and a half
two hours a little more
it's a consolidation of real life so you
have to cut out the dull bits so this is
also I would say a common mistake that I
see with writers is that the need to
explain the entrance into a scene and
the and leaving we don't need to see
characters o walking into a door walking
down the hallway unless of course it's
very purposeful like you're doing a
thriller and someone's walking down a
hallway and there may be someone in
another room that they don't know about
so that's there it's very purposeful but
we don't need to see a character
entering and saying hi oh I just came in
from the grocery store we don't need to
play that scene out and then see they
carry Joe say okay I'm leaving now I'm
exaggerating a bit but there have their
scripts that I've read where every scene
practically starts with the character
entering and exiting another example
would be if we see a husband and wife
and they are heading to the in-laws we
don't have to see them get in the car
put the kids and there are a little you
know and the seat belts and the baby
seat drive the full distance obviously
or even part of the distance and we see
them get out of the driveway walk up the
door ring the doorbell so that's an
example of you cut out deliberately
those dull bits long order sometimes
I'll say to writers think of the law and
order edits so you may have a scene
where one of the you know one of the
detectives says so do you know about
have you ever seen this victim you know
what
last time I saw her she was partying
with her friend Jessie where do you find
Jessie oh she's always hanging out at
such-and-such Club boom we're at the
club and sometimes we might pick up a
scene mid-conversation
so that's one example of cutting out
dull bits that's a great analogy I like
that do you think people get some of
that confused with novel writing yes
okay
and even in novels you don't always have
you know character entering and entering
but exiting but in with novel writing
one of the things that you can do is get
fully inside the head of your character
so she's walking down the street and she
sees a leaf and it reminds her of when
she was young this is I can factor and
lost her virginity and we don't have the
luxury in scripts you can of course do
well fantasy sequence or flashback but
generally speaking you can't do go on
and you can't as like in a book you can
describe smells in a movie you can't
really describe a smell you could say
that character burns toast and there's
smoke coming out of the toaster but so
it definitely has to be much more
economical and one of the things I said
a lot I was an English major where my
greatest teachers was Shakespeare and
when I say that is that of course I had
wonderful teachers who were guides but
one of the greatest teachers is reading
great authors great screenwriters great
playwrights I talk about a lot of times
with writers getting them feedback about
not writing with exposition Harold
Pinter is a master of subtext I
recommend Matthew whiner and that Mad
Men the characters rarely say exactly
what they're feeling there's so much
subtext and it just makes the writing
that much more powerful
do you think the the lost art of novel
reading will come back I don't know if I
feel it's that lost even though Barnes
and Noble sadly is you know closing and
but I think they're just so many
wonderful books out there and I know so
many people who are in book clubs and I
J K Rowling bless her I mean she is
responsible for getting more people more
children into reading and there's so
many great authors out there and of
course as we know books are a great
great source for for movies Hollywood
loves intellectual properties they like
source material
it's another strategy sometimes with
screenwriters they have a script and
it's well written and it they've been
having a hard time for whatever reasons
gaining traction sometimes them they may
turn it into a book and if the book
starts to get traction then they sort of
reverse-engineer and go back and then
sell it as sell the script sell the book
and the script based on the book scripts
are just awful when the writer tells you
everything did I say that mine said that
okay who uh she's not a screenwriter
she's not a producer she has been in the
business a long time as a unit publicist
and she she has exquisite taste in films
and I remember asking her because I was
asked that for I think a topic of an
article and I said what would you say is
one of the things that makes has made
you want to get involved with a script
and what do you think makes the script
really good and her we came out of her
mouth is what makes scripts awful is
when characters tell you everything so
examples are if a husband and a wife
let's say a wife saw her husband having
lunch with another woman that she didn't
know about and he comes home
from work he's like hi honey how's your
day and she were to say what she'll
probably say in real life is it nothing
with that kind of you know I mean
Matthew waters a master of the subtext I
recommend looking at just about any
episode of Mad Men but much less
interesting so or she might say is that
the husband comes in and says what did
you do today and I was in a similar
situation once with and I did not say I
saw you with another woman having lunch
today I wanted him to like I wanted to
maybe catch him in a lie I said or
actually like well I you know what did
she do today and he said nothing special
really did you have lunch somewhere
interesting what are you talking about
and like maybe one of the things that I
love is that if you really play along
with that you can also play with the
audience in terms of them thinking oh
yeah he was having an affair then we
find out that it was an interior
decorator and he was surprising his wife
by he just bought a little vacation home
and he was making sure that or you just
like was renting in Malibu a place and
he wanted to make sure all this stuff
was special for their anniversary and
then what can happen is if she keeps
testing him and testing him and and she
like starts bringing up old stuff about
how he pisses her off that scene could
end with him not telling her what the
surprise was and the couple deciding you
never trust me you know what I was gonna
do something nice with for you and screw
you I want a divorce I'm just spinning
here and I'm not saying that that's you
know they the greatest scene but that's
an example of when you play with subtext
versus characters saying everything that
they're thinking another example if you
take a streetcar named desire with
Blanche and Stanley and Stella and if
you had
lanch saying well i really have been
working as a prostitute and I'm
depressed and I have nowhere else to
live game over like not very interesting
so if you think about it in those terms
um yeah it's and it's really reflecting
how people are in real life people don't
always say exactly what they're thinking
and feeling oh not at all yeah but
that's what makes it so interesting too
because you like you said going along on
the ride wondering will there be a
raised eyebrow that will reveal
something or exactly versus because then
it just has like this flat tone and it
really doesn't replicate human life and
I feel like that's one of the things
that I was saying earlier when you would
ask what I love about movies is that we
can vicariously put ourselves in the
other characters situation and we can
say I've been in a situation like that I
didn't want to confront my husband if
he'd been with another woman and so on
and so forth some or that like if you
can tell sometimes if there's like
gossip or somebody said something about
you so they come in how are you exactly
yes and you know they want something
from that statement and then we can I
ourself in the the feeling of the person
who is suspecting that maybe they were
talking about her but they're not coming
out and saying right so I think that's
such a good point that you bring up is
that it really engages us so much more
and because that's a comment that I said
a lot you want to be engaged I mean good
writing good script the scripts at
command attention is with an
extraordinary capacity to engage your
reader and that's usually through really
smart dialogue like that like what you
were talking about you talked about two
scripts that don't propel the character
forward mm-hmm so can we can we have
maybe some examples of ones that would
and then ones that don't or just some
themes all right well gosh okay Breaking
Bad is that
a great example of an escalation of
situations and the so I would say that's
the character every step that he takes
there's a consequence and it leads to
another and another and then the
character might try and get himself out
of it but it's it's it's kind of like
the notion of Macbeth once you create or
do something bad it is it has its own
momentum the I it's hard to say without
really doing specifics but basically
every scene you want to feel that you're
advancing the story you're advancing the
plot even if a character has a setback
that's there's still it there's still
one of the I guess best ways to think
about it is that there's the core spine
of the story where a character primary
character or you may have an ensemble
but that each has a goal that there's a
primary objective that the character is
trying to obtain and the obstacles that
get in the way that prevent them from
that and how they even if it's a step
back but then they're still trying to
overcome that obstacle there or in most
movies successful movies follow that
formula I hate to say formula cuz I
don't like two things being being
formulaic and an example really where
stories are not propelled forward is
when I think the writer loses focus that
the focus is too diffused and one of the
common reasons for that would be when
there are too many characters when a
writer is introducing so many characters
that rather than get to know one or a
few really well we're getting glimpses
of all these different characters but
none of them because they don't have
time to develop them particularly well
and so we don't have a core sense of
what a character is primary foe
kiss or a group of characters primary
focus and goal is what are the obstacles
that get in their way so I think anytime
there's a really diffuse focus and then
scripts don't they one of just being
very dispersed and rather than having a
through-line how does the lead
characters arc relate to structure very
good question
when people talk about structure a lot
referring to the classic structure that
we'll hear in Syd field and Bob McKee
and I think both of those writers there
are books on screenwriting I think are
really I think every screenwriters
should aspiring screenwriter should
should read those books the question
about structure you'll hear okay there
has to be act 1 act 2 act 3 and inciting
incident sometimes writers get so bogged
down with oh no I've got it here too -
these they're really guidelines and it's
really beginning middle and end when you
think of act 1 X 2 X 3 I know some other
people are talking about 7 & 8 X
structures and so on but really with the
story you want to have it can take away
all the terminology you're really
looking at a beginning middle and end
the character you're usually starting
out with a heroine or hero and that they
have a strong emotional want I think
it's very that's really how we usually
get engaged whether it's the heroine in
The Hunger Games she wants to protect
her sister and save her sister from
dying you know in these these crazy
games and then the the journey the path
is very clear she wants to survive and
live and in the process make sure that
other people she cares about don't get
hurt the and then we have so many
obstacles along the way because at every
twist and turn there are some things
some element going against her
threatening to destroy her
soshe's that's a very physical type of
obstacle that she has to continually try
to overcome a movie that I loved in
terms of its character arc and maybe
it's an oldie but goodie is an officer
and a gentleman
you had the character who in the very
opening you see that he is the father
who is it
drunk womanizer doesn't appreciate his
son at all doesn't think his sons going
to amount to anything when he tells him
that he's enlisted he I think makes fun
of him what you think you're a man now
the whole movie is really about a guy
with so much armor and bad attitude when
he first gets to training camp he
doesn't share with other of his bunk
mates on other soldiers and he's just
really not a good guy
but we know that deep down inside he's
carrying all this emotional hurt and we
know that he really does want to be
better and not wind up like his dad and
then you had the amazing performance by
Lou Gossett jr. as his captain sergeant
who winds up breaking him down so you
have a character trying to better
himself and then finally when he's
broken is when he starts to become a
better guy and becomes an officer and a
gentleman and winds up with the girl and
so on but usually there's a character
flaw or vulnerability and we see that
getting chipped away and chipped away
until they're healed and that also
applies in romantic comedies as well and
I can think of a couple of examples
whether it's proposal or something about
Polly where you know the Ben Stiller
character is very anal and the last
thing he wanted was the Jennifer Aniston
character and through that relationship
he winds up becoming less uptight and
really capable
of loving what about in the wrestler
going back to that such a well that's
see not that's a really good question
not every movie has to have this like
huge epiphany or growth the I'm trying
to think the I think the wrestler is
thinking of something about Schmidt I
was thinking also of fellini's movie La
Strada with Anthony Quinn where the
character is in a relationship with this
woman that he totally takes for granted
and the oh it would be a spoiler alert
at the end of the movie we see a man who
really is broken and realizes that how
that he really is all alone so maybe
there's a sense of growth or victory in
the triumph of awareness very quiet kind
of Arc in Something About Schmidt that
Jack Nicholson character is looking for
connection looking for connection
reconnecting with family friends
whatever he is his left since his wife
died and realizing a sense that his life
has really passed him by and at the end
of the movie the child that he was
trying to be a pen pal with and finally
responded and it was so touching is it's
the notion that we all we all want his
love in here that he was finally
developing a relationship and a love
connection it was so small but it was
meaningful and the wrestler what was so
sad was that he really he messed up he
messed up connecting with his daughter
in the only place where he belonged was
the ring even if that was going to be
where he was going to it was going to
kill him so it just but you did see a
character who had a strong emotional
want and I would say how structure
in terms of beginning middle and end
relates to characters arc is starting
out with their strong emotional want
what are the obstacles along the way and
the wrestler the obstacle was that he's
been a screw-up certainly as a father
he's the obstacles are he's no longer
he's older and been through a lot in
battle in the ring and that he the
obstacle trying to reconnect and get a
daughter who he really abandoned to love
him and then he gets in his own way but
we're sustaining this characters
emotional want he has a setback and so
on and we see it through to the end
whether they wind up satisfying and
learning or wind up going down and we
just get a glimpse of their humanity
Wendy we had this comment come in a
couple days ago on YouTube and the
viewer asked what should writers be
concerned with when revising their
second or third draft of something a
really good question because I know like
we all talked about a first draft but
invariably the biggest part of writing
your script is the rewrite in the
rewriting the rewrite I think the
biggest danger is well put it this way
the purpose and the benefit is that it's
going to get clearer and crisper and
better and tighter so the danger is when
you lose sight of what your core vision
is now there are two ways this could
happen first if you've never haven't had
a strong core vision to begin with then
each draft the goal should be to refine
what that is and maybe the writer needs
to do an outline first and be really
clear and I do recommend I think Blake
Snyder has a very effective beat sheet
that's a useful tool and again I tell
writers that use it as a general guide
and a general map but don't feel that
you have to adhere to like
oh I've got it insert this moment at
exactly this page or try to contrive
things you must be organic to your
follow your own organic process the
another thing just with like about rules
and following formulas I'd like to use
as an example when you see a great prima
ballerina like I saw many years ago
Makarova who was one of the preeminent
ballerinas when I was growing up and she
you know that she practiced her bars and
she knew her craft but when she got on
stage you then abandon it it becomes
second nature that you should know your
craft but that you can be free enough to
let the muse flow through you if you're
so manufactured where you're trying to
hit every plot point and you're writing
from that place you're not going to have
the magic and the kind of flow that a
writer needs to have to really create
magical characters and dialogue and
story so but it's helpful to have this
map so this is for a writer who might
not have core vision to begin with for
most writers they do have a core vision
of their piece and the danger becomes
when you lose your Center and you start
listening to you're like a weed in the
wind that you keep swaying so this
person said I should do this so I'm
going to do that this person said you
keep going just in too many different
directions it is an art to be a artur a
balance to be able to take advice
feedback suggestions from other people
let it go through a sieve earth-like
filter and something that occurs to me
is to maybe approach the advice the way
they make recommendations with
meditation when you're when thoughts
come to you it's not that you're so
rigid about I can't think any thoughts I
can
thing any thoughts so the same way
you're not being richer than that I'm
not going to take anyone suggestions and
you're not saying I'm gonna take
everyone's suggestions you okay let's
see this was a good idea I'm gonna let
that percolate this idea I don't think
it really fits in with the vision so I'm
gonna put that one aside
I'll reexamine it just in case there's
something there I need to look at and
there are others that you may go oh this
person they don't get it at all
maybe I'm doing something that's not
making it clear enough but I don't I
don't think they're the right person to
give me advice for this you cannot a you
can't be a pleaser where you're trying
to please everybody but generally
speaking if there is valuable feedback
then to take it in and put it through
your own filter and process and see how
you can address so the biggest danger is
losing sense of self and trying to
please everybody and then you wind up
with mush and that's nothing it's
neither here and are there there's a no
vision so can we just define coefficient
here would be a really good example I
had a client who had a one-hour drama
that was inspired by his life
experiences and he had a really really
interesting story based on his
profession and he sent me the draft he
had told me the logline and what he had
done and then I read the draft and I was
like this doesn't sound at all like your
story and he had changed the protagonist
to a woman which can be fine but there
were it felt so manufactured and
contrived and so I just said a very
innocent question I said I'm really
curious because what you would pitch to
me based on your life experience was so
fascinating and riveting and I felt like
and that's what really interested me
about the idea for this pilot and I
didn't see
what I know of you I didn't see any of
you in this pilot whether it was a male
or female character and he told me that
he had taken a number of writing
workshops were or script coverage
services and certainly there are good
ones out there but one they said you
should change it to a female you should
make the protagonist a woman not a man
someone else said oh you should give her
this backstory and you should give her
such and such kind of relationship with
her mother and with an abusive boyfriend
and it became so far removed from what I
thought was really the core vision or
essence of the story that he wanted to
tell and he let go of that and came up
with something that and I he said I
didn't even want to write this but I
thought I should you know that these
were people who were telling me that I
that I should so that's what I think you
need to stick with your core vision that
would be an example it's a great place
to start on we talked about being able
to take constructive criticism and not
being defensive and being open to the
notes what if people are giving you
super nice feedback about things and it
feels disingenuous and you're not sure
is this just a person that's trying to
please me mm-hmm it doesn't have to be a
family member or friend and how do we
see through that it's a good question I
think one is to say when you're seeking
constructive criticism because it is
coming from a I mean I this is how I'd
like to give notes and if I'm asking
someone to evaluate something for me I
may say I need you to be gentle this is
my style I don't respond well to someone
who's going to shred everything but I do
want honest feedback so if someone a lot
of writers will say to me and I usually
say before I do consulting I say I want
to make sure that you want honest
feedback certainly everyone has an
opinion what you will get from me is
an informed opinion being that I do feel
it as one of my strengths as we get
older I think we come to know what some
of our strengths are my affinity for
literature from a young age to you know
working in the business and working for
a long time with writers and loving the
process and that when you as a writer
when you ask an opinion that you a lot
of writers will say to me I want an
honest I will don't be afraid you can be
brutal
etc it's not my desire or style to be
brutal because I don't like my teachers
I did not feel that's constructive but I
do feel that I also say to my clients
I'm not doing you a favor if I don't
provide an honest assessment based on my
experiences in the business based on my
knowledge of how other industry
executives respond to material it's not
the only opinion certainly but it will
be an informed opinion so I think that
when writers are asking for feedback
that they if someone's really like oh I
loved everything I loved everything that
they you say I don't want you to just
say this to be nice if you have
something that you think is constructive
and I can improve I would really
appreciate that I would really value
that doesn't really matter if a
protagonist is active or passive I I
think it does
I think nobody wants to watch a passive
character and even in real life if we I
guess there are some exceptions like
leaving Las Vegas where you had a
depressed alcoholic who said that was
his journey and that's what the movie
was about and of course it was based on
a very well known book the but even like
a movie like Zelig where i guess it's a
character who's passive who's assuming
other characters personalities that are
other individuals
personalities assuming their identities
that he's actively doing that but most
cases and then a certain way I guess you
could say in leaving Las Vegas and
Nicolas Cage character was even though
he's sitting on a self a most of the
time but he was pretty committed and
actively pursuing drinking himself to
death and dying in Las Vegas he was
committed to not leaving Las Vegas I
guess they think that otherwise it's
it's just boring and even in with the
writing of a script it's best not to use
passive verbs such as he is being he is
he you always want to keep it active
like he's walking it's not like the
sidewalks are passing him by i but I
feel that you always want to have an
active protagonist sometimes you get
scripts that are where they'll change
someone may change tenses you it always
has to be active present tense talking
again about like getting too much advice
to change a character even though it's
sort of like your central journey and
you're writing about it do you think
people layer it with other parts of
another character because it's too close
to home they don't want to totally write
their story but the central message or
value of the film is a certain way but
because they don't really want to have
it be their own biopic really that they
pepper in these different things and it
waters it down so they make the
protagonist a female when it's really a
man's journey right oh or a young man's
coming-of-age story now I think that
come in it's interesting because with
the changing of protagonist from a male
to female I understand that I mean if
you take a movie like speed it did work
that it was a female but you could have
reversed the sexes and it could have
worked the movie that Sandra Bullock did
with not too long ago it was originally
I think written as a
for George Clooney and they changed it
to a female I'm not adverse to that at
all and I've had instances where I might
have where I've done that and sometimes
it might been this a white lead and you
can make it an african-american
character or a latin-american character
and that's fine and that's fresh you
know to not have to you so there are
times when it can be really really great
and improve the story but it's when a
person is compromising the the essence
and spirit of what they are connecting
with and it's fine to I mean I've done
true stories where we couldn't use the
actual characters names so we might have
changed the their profession so if one
was a computer engineer maybe we made
him a real estate agent or if the story
took place in Connecticut we changed it
to Colorado
things like that are fine but it's you
don't you want to always have a
connection with the true essence and
spirit of the story and you accord I go
back to that word for me it's a core
vision of something that moves Ewing and
compels you and is a really strong story
that you want to tell and at the heart
of it is usually a it might be an image
that triggers something or usually a
character with what I call a strong
emotional want that I had mentioned you
a right we talked about that I feel like
I'm always learning from respected
colleagues and associates and there's a
screenwriter who I really really respect
and he was the one who would we can talk
about motivation
I love with his phrase was that every
character that you become engaged with
especially protagonist in almost every
great film has this a character with a
very strong emotional want and need and
actually another book that I love
Stanislavski an actor prepares
he gives backstory for what the actor
needs to do before entering a scene and
he talks about a character having a
super objective which is the grand
overriding life objective and then the
immediate objective so maybe the big
objective is I want to be retired and
live in the Bahamas my immediate
objective I need to get this job
promotion or I mean a wolf just from
this you could have different genres
immediately I can tell you that the
different immediate objective is that he
wants to kill the man he works for
and get his money and steal his money so
two totally different movies with when
you change what the immediate objective
is and the super objective thinking -
when you talk about books an adaptation
I love is White Oleander oh yeah that
was really oh my gosh amazing film and
and book as well if you were to change
Alice and Loehmann's character to a male
it seems like then you would have to
change all of the foster parents to men
as well because it was a it was a
relationship between the mother and
daughters right how toxic that was and
it does create different dynamics I
think also because that was based on
source material a really well-respected
book and a best-seller that you wouldn't
change it and there probably wouldn't it
if it wasn't based on the best-selling
book you could go other way but there
are two different stories and I think
again ever if it was a screenwriter or
the author what is truest to what's
getting you going what is inspiring you
is it you know dynamics between a mother
and daughter are different than between
a father and son so I think it's really
connecting as a writer when I say core
vision another way to describe it is the
source of inspiration the thing that
gets you really excited
about the story what is the journey you
want to tell right into for the
motivation of all those mothers whether
it was Michelle Pfeiffer's character mhm
and then all of the you know Renee
Zellweger had her own um you know
motivation mm-hmm and and and Robyn
writes care it was so they all had these
interesting motivations yeah very much
yeah and that's I think it's important
for screamers to really I think we can
never take for granted not knowing our
characters well enough now if it's
purely an action film like a speed it's
not so important to the ride is the
movie the or the mummy the original one
the it's there are motivations clearly
and a strong plot but it's really less
about deep character development but
anytime you're doing if it's generally
speaking if it's a psychological
thriller family drama comedy you need to
not take for granted that you can't know
your characters enough a lot of writers
don't go through that step of really
knowing them and immersing themselves in
that character or characters I mean and
it comes up with like who are they what
you know where are they when that the
movie starts are they in a happy place
are they in a sad place did they just
break up with a boyfriend you are they
on top of the world did they just get
fired
these so knowing those kinds of things
and I apply what Stanislavski said which
is what is their super objective what do
they want and life so to go through all
of those things is there even if it's
not in the script is there a pivotal
thing that happened that damaged them so
those types of things I usually give
clients and working with the character
questionnaire to help unleash all those
things about their character I so
because you can't really write from an
abstract place just oh he's a guy
I like that the questionnaire that's
great how can a screenwriter create a
hero that we want to follow I keep
saying the same thing but it's for me
that you find you start with the
characters a really strong emotional
want and I feel like we take any any
successful film critically acclaimed
film it's always character that has that
strong emotional want whether it's a in
mention with the wrestler that my
upbringing I have nothing in common with
a wrestler the nut boys don't cry a
million dollar yeah baby baby I don't
have anything in common with a
white-trash girl who wants to box but
boy did she have a want yeah and so
that's and I don't mean to say that in a
I'm trying to say the opposite that so
I'm not trying to make a judgment or be
snobby I'm saying that a great film has
a character with a strong emotional want
that no matter what our upbringing our
race we can identify and relate to that
character the the protagonist and Barry
Jenkins film moonlight I don't know what
it's like to grow up as a young black
gay man in Miami but we can all relate
to feeling like an outsider at some
point in our lives wanting to be
accepted having very extraordinarily
difficult situations and there was such
beauty in the way this character was
able to persevere and overcome and then
it was also told structurally in a very
interesting manner and again there is an
example where that didn't follow what a
lot of people would say is a you know
the classic Syd field or Bob McKee
structure it was told almost like three
more I would say oh not quite Faulkner
but there was a novelistic approach to
it I think you can break structure
when you're when you understand it to
begin with and you're here you're
hitting everything else really right so
writing authentic characters compelling
dialogue compelling situations and it is
well structured so but I do feel it's
like tapping into that thing that we as
humans want and can identify with and
what are universal flaws that that a
character may have switching gears just
a tiny bit have you ever not taken on a
project and for what reasons all the
time I mean most of the time and that's
the fact that what most writers are
faced with that it is a game of mostly
rejections and I know as a producer I
feel like if I wind up optioning a
project writers have bent a lot of odds
to have someone decide they want to
option the project I then have to try
and go and sell it I had a project once
where it took me a year and I sent it to
every single it was a network to like
every single network and this was a time
when you had to wait the protocol was
you couldn't take it somewhere else
until you heard back today you can do
multiple submissions but that was a
protocol back then and it was the last
network that I took it to and the head
of the network who's very well respected
industry individual the executive showed
us his comment what they would do is the
executives would every month they would
gather the top tiers of projects that
they've read and liked and they would
give it to their boss he would read it
on the weekend ours came back and we had
been rejected like 12 places but I
always knew it was a good story and a
lot of the rejections were that it just
doesn't fit into our mandate we're not
doing this type of story right now and
anyway he wrote in the margin this is a
good story so I
a genuine once said that all it takes is
one yes
now it's also fine balance because if
you were getting no no no no no
consistently with feedback that like the
feedback that I was getting lesson this
isn't a good story it was this isn't the
right project for us right now or we
have something similar to this if you're
getting feedback where someone says and
I never heard this quite a bit I like
the concept I didn't love the execution
and I can elaborate on that or I I
really like the concept but I didn't
love the protagonist I didn't feel that
character was developed enough and
that's why I'm very tenacious when
working with writers before taking it
out because I know what the odds are I
mean obviously a lot of writers know the
odds but a lot of writers will say well
I see stuff get made all the time that's
not very good we don't know the
circumstances of how and why that
project got made if it went through too
many revisions and it lost its center it
went through different regime changes
nobody starts out trying to make a bad
movie with the exception of one I can
think of and takes pride and it's been a
huge hit and a cult hit because there
are two movies I can reference one
because it's out right now the the
disaster artist well but even that guy
didn't start out to make a bad movie and
it obviously developed a cult following
because of its uniqueness that way but
the you know no one is when people say
oh but there are writers who get stuff
me and it's not very good I feel it's
such a poor model to even reference
because so should that be your model
that like okay well my movie doesn't
have to be perfect I don't care if it's
that great other people's can get made
no my feeling is that you need to make
sure that it's at the absolutely best
level it can be
and and and if you do get consistent
feedback where people are saying I'm
just not loving the character enough and
then I think you need to go back to your
script and then talk to your buddies in
the industry whose opinions you respect
and say do me a favor will you take a
look at this again let me know what you
think maybe I could make better maybe
going to workshop it definitely do your
research to see because you know which
would I think there are some workshops
that are better than others and you can
do your due diligence by talking to
fellow writers who maybe have taken a
particular workshop what they've gotten
out of it what the results have been
like and or of course work with you know
a script consultant other industry
colleagues like I mentioned assistant if
you you're starting out you may know
assistants who work for agents or
production companies or studios and have
them read it and give you feedback do we
have a lot of screenwriters in their 20s
that watch our videos and they're just
starting out and they're in an early
stage of their writing careers is there
any advice you can give to them oh sure
luck they've won I think one of the best
tips is it was I I heard a female runner
say when she came out to LA she spent
the first year reading every single
pilot that had been picked up that she
could get her hands on and that could
and also maybe reading pilots of series
from a couple years ago I do feel that's
when I certainly Shakespeare for me was
one of my best teachers just
understanding how well-defined his
characters were the dialogue and the
conflicts and they you know the
characters needs and wants and what gets
in their way and I mean it the stakes
you don't get bigger than Shakespeare
with Macbeth or Hamlet and so I
there are great teachers and great
Matthew one or we you can watch Mad Men
absolutely you know you can watch a lot
of series but there is something about
seeing the written word the other thing
is an exercise and I think this is a
very powerful exercise and might not
seem like fun but it can be fun is to
watch if your I did this actually when I
was in my 20s starting out officer and a
gentleman and this is before you could
download scripts on the internet I did I
watched the whole movie and I wrote down
as I was watching it what each scene was
so I had to pause a lot but in what it
does is it really helps you understand
and get a feel for rhythm and structure
almost through osmosis through that
process of doing it and the point of
doing it isn't so you can go and you're
not plagiarizing or copying it's to get
you to just understand rhythms of scenes
and how they flow from one to the next
and what and you you can see when you're
doing it okay whereas what's the act one
the Act one break usually it's supposed
to be around page 27 in a feature so you
see where that kind of flows when you're
copying you know a script and if you
don't have to do every single line baby
okay Richard Richard Gere's with his
father they wake up right after they've
had an evening of debauchery and hookers
and Richard Gere's now off to to
training camp in the military then the
next scene and I don't remember exactly
but let's say the next scene is he's on
a bus and we see exterior they did the
facility then next scene maybe we see
Debra Winger as a waitress I don't
remember everything so forgive me but it
also gets you into the understanding and
the that screenwriter is a wonderful
screenwriter the it gets you into seeing
how when I was talking about not
including the dull bits you could see
beautiful juxtapositions like he's off
to the military and then maybe the next
thing he's in line and being asked to
salute and it's just it's a wonderful
exercise this woman who has became a
successful writer in television she read
pilot so if you feel like you're want to
be a half-hour person and if you want to
do multicam and you feel like NBC CBS
ABC style sit comes or your thing
which are multicam versus single-camera
which is more like Aziz Ansari and the
marvelous mrs. Mazal master of none then
get those scripts read them see how they
introduce the characters see how
distinct all the voices are they're so
distinct and these will be some of your
best teachers continuing on with advice
for the the 20-something year old
writers that we get feedback from I
think you mentioned that you went to see
the writer Jorge Luis Borges speak yes
and that he said I'm finally getting
better and it was 80-some yes right no
cuz this is something that happens a lot
writers will say well when will it be
ready when will it be ready what or it's
ready it's ready and I have a client who
I love dearly and we worked very closely
together and I many many drafts ago she
said okay this is it this is the final
draft and I'm like I would love for it
to be the final draft I don't want it's
not late and I mean I do with consulting
but it's not like I want my biggest
baileywick if you will or heyday is to
have a really strong script that I can
take out to the market and get set up
with a production company studio network
etc and so I'm reading it and she one of
the things we had changed the location
from overseas to New York and we changed
one of the characters from an Italian to
a New York Italian and she changed his
name so I think he was Giovanni and then
he became
so when I was reading that script the
character she kept going back and forth
with the name and that's just a very
simple fix but you know here's someone
saying it's final and I wanted to be
final and it wasn't you know a hundred
percent perfect yet just even on a very
cosmetic level so the notion of and when
you brought up jorge luis borges that i
was in college and he came to our campus
and spoke and he was in his I think he
was about 82 and he was going blind and
he said Here I am and then going blind
I'm 82 and I feel like I am just now
getting good at my craft and here was a
man who received some of the highest
literary honors you can get and it was
inspiring and when I see younger writers
saying you know well it it's done it or
it's good enough for it and any writer
at any age can really say that I feel
like any time I've watched on some of
the talk show interviews with
best-selling book authors amazing
directors screenwriters very often when
they speak now they say it's taken them
seven years so I feel like and when I
see someone like bohr Hayes speak the
way he did if people who are such
masters it's taking them like seven
years or more
or in the case of bore case a lifetime
to just feel like he's getting good
then we need to relish enjoy soak up the
process of continuing to get better and
better and better so that's and I I mean
anyone we greatly respect whether today
if it's Aaron Sorkin or Jason Reitman
they all say that you know they go
through multiple I mean
I mean I think it's like gone through
3040 drops on some of his projects and
with the Aaron Sorkin I don't remember
how many like he does but I also did
hear him say once that it takes him it
takes him anywhere from a year to 18
months to deliver a first draft he's
turning over and over the characters and
so I feel like if these great masters
who really have excelled in their fields
in their craft if it takes them so long
why do we think that if we're just
starting out that we should be able to
do it sooner
and I'm offer if it can happen soon
great but the process is the process
right and Jason is of a generation where
they want things faster yes so that
that's very telling in that sense
because I feel like now everything's so
sped up and instantaneous that it
heightens all that you know you hear on
Twitter and see all this stuff about
this person's just been discovered but
we don't realize we don't realize and
I've heard also with some great writers
being interviewed you know people say oh
they just wrote it one or two drafts and
then when you hear them speak they say
that it was they did multiple drafts
I just feel like basically there really
aren't shortcuts I do think there's an
anomaly maybe someone can write
something and it just everything's
aligned and the muse and the ability and
it just flows out of you and I think
that can't happen but it really is an
anomaly most of the time they're things
require more and more refinement and
craft it kind of goes back to what you
said earlier about the female showrunner
who's achieved great success but she
says people want the outcome but they
probably wouldn't want to do all the
hours and and all the probably late
nights behind a computer stressing over
some little deal yeah yeah and I think
that's a huge thing people don't see
some of that work that
it's true and and they just want the
faster around and it's human nature
nobody want to have to put it exactly
but it's true this is a common question
I ask but it usually ends up having
great results and that is of your IMDB
credits which one whether it was a short
TV series whatever which one taught you
the most and why without naming of
course sure object I feel like each one
has taught me and it's really from the
people that I worked with that I learned
so one of the things I feel like my
first job I worked for a producer I felt
was a master at cultivating interest in
projects um so he knew how to generate
interest and position and I learned in
cases where I might have missed out on a
project by not being assertive enough
and I say one project which I sold and
it was such a great high I was it was at
a time when I was told that it was at a
particular network that they had spent
their financing for the fiscal year and
we had an option on the book and it was
about to be up and that also it was a
period piece and they said we're not
doing period we're not doing period and
I won't saying but this reads to the
president of the production company this
wreath so hipped the sweets so
contemporary most women today would die
to do what this girl did back then and I
would my boss actually said to me after
that you know be careful you shouldn't
be so boisterous you know with the
president anyway to make a long story
short I wound up speaking to the network
to where we had a deal and got the
president of the company and hurt VP's
all on board and they wound up optioning
the book and it was a series so there
were gonna be three books sadly there
was a regime change after we started the
process and we did get a first script
and
the new regime decided that they didn't
want to do it again and that happens in
the business and it's unfortunate but it
is part of the business and hopefully
you just continue to build on the
successes and you're always going to
have failures you learn from your
failures I mean that case sometimes
there are things outside of one's
control but what I learned there was to
have the courage of my convictions I
remember there was an executive at the
EBC who had said to his group and they
did really wonderful programming if
we're going to fail I want us to fail
big because we tried not fail because we
were scared and if you look at any
network and breakout shows they were
taking risks and going against the grain
and whether it was married with children
at the time x-files was on there was
nothing like that and then everybody
wanted to copy and do something like
x-files and the and I remember the sell
of x-files was the head of the network
saying to Chris Carter I just want you
to do what you really want to do so that
was brave for the executive in hindsight
we can all say that's fine but he was
really encouraging the pure voice and
creativity of that particular writer and
boy when you you know can follow your
vision and your passion and you have
combined with the talent to deliver and
the support and the right studio behind
you can really deliver something that's
iconic and you you know becomes part of
the our pop culture and everything the
going back to the so what I had learned
so I really felt strongly because of
that reward that I would always follow
the courage of my convictions so I think
it's really important to do that with
other movies I would say I learned from
a really intelligent boss writer
director who's no longer with us that
just not to have a lazy mind and never
go for the easy solution he was
rated with development and when what
other stories we had and I learned so
much from him was to really look at the
authenticity of how a character would
behave and not just go for the obvious
easy generic solution so that really
taught me I think to be diligent and try
and find the unexpected behavior in
characters and so anyway - I could be
here for a long time but I have I've
learned from really I think our greatest
teachers are working with other people
who who are good at what they do
what does writing a marketable
screenplay mean great question probably
one of my favorite questions I often say
that you can have a great idea super
high concept and I think I referenced
previously I've heard story ideas that
go oh my god that is great I want option
before I even read it and then I read it
and it's not well executed so if you
have a great concept that's not well
executed chances are that it will not
sell if you have a high concept that is
well executed you have a much better
chance of a getting salt conversely you
can have a project that is totally not
high concept but if it is beautifully
executed it then becomes marketable so
for example if we take a movie like Juno
and I'll define high concept high
concept is The Hangover a bunch of guys
you know from the movie poster I mean a
lot of people I know a lot of your
audience knows what high concept is but
there are those who don't and it's
terminology we use lawrence basically
where the concept is very big and
immediately recognizable like from a
movie poster so the hangover and it's
the guys are you know we all know it's
the hangover in its vegas you can tell
from the movie poster and they all look
like they're Iraq and
it's the 48 hours before bachelor is to
walk down the aisle at his bachelor
party they go to Vegas and I his friends
lose him and they have now fort and
don't have any recollection what
happened the night before and have 48
hours to find him before the wedding
that's one example of big big concept
speed is a big concept anything that's
based on a brand like transformers it
has a immediately recognizable built-in
audience brand value so the opposite of
that would be a movie like Slumdog
Millionaire in fact most of the movies
that when the Oscars are not high
concept Slumdog Millionaire Million
Dollar Baby okay if you were to pitch
this I'm gonna do a you know not justice
to the movie but if you think about it
like trying to get a studio to but this
is a story about a girl who comes from
trailer park and she wants to be a boxer
and she's mentored by this older dude
and she wants up getting entering
herself to the point where she becomes
paralyzed on the way down and she
paralyzed from the waist down and
basically asks him as an act of kindness
to do euthanasia so she does okay who
would buy that nah you know Slumdog
Millionaire this is was a great story
movie no known act American actor but
you did have a an a-list director Danny
Boyle so that is what definitely helped
get it made and it was also based on a
book swing blade another one
magnificently written script and some of
these movies would definitely be harder
to get done today but the you take Juno
you you know family drama teenage girl
gets pregnant I mean really that used to
be like an after-school special or and
no disrespect you know more of a TV
movie than a feature that would build
such a big following
this year ladybird you know that's not a
high concept rite of passage with the
young girl and but it was so well
written and it resonated so much with
people the mother-daughter relationship
the notion of growing up in a small town
and so the what makes a script
marketable the script like Juno and with
Lady Bird the the quality of the writing
the freshness of the characters the
truthfulness of the characters that then
becomes marketable so that comes down to
me saying we write your best work I
don't know any executives other people
may I don't know any executives who have
optioned a script if they didn't care
for the dialogue the writing they didn't
think it was I mean structure maybe is
the least offensive you know I hate I
can be a good idea and maybe the
structure is not great but there the the
characters are compelling the
situation's compelling and the dialogue
is good and I just don't know anyone who
buy scripts if those elements aren't
there so therefore I think if you are
gonna make a profession as a
screenwriter it's not an easy profession
at all you have to roll up your sleeves
and really get in there and I I read I
mean I'm working right now with someone
who just graduated from film school and
it's quite his his writings were really
good there are some elements that I
think needed to be much more pronounced
what the underlying theme is and the
purpose of the journey and some things
that didn't track what the character is
but there's a lot of talent there but I
didn't think it's ready quite to take
out yet but he's doing some work now and
he'll get there I mean there's there's a
there's a lot of talent and there's a
lot of there's a lot of writing that we
isn't very strong and I think the
biggest death to a writer is to is to
not be able to take notes well and I
don't mean just any notes to be open to
constructive feedback and to want to put
in their dues so I think that's the
biggest killer as well as trying to
please too many people and not listening
to your own inner voice and I just say
in terms of marketability what gets
agents attention producers studio
networks is ace is it that you'll hear a
strong voice that there's something
really fresh about a person has a point
of view and that the character writing
the Quentin Tarantino is such a strong
voice and I would say that Greta Gerwig
you know as a strong voice and we could
go on but I can't think of it their
names but you know in even what's going
back to Lady Bird or just just briefly
we went to see the post and
unfortunately the movie didn't play so
we all had to leave the theatre but I
talked to a man who was maybe in his
late 50s and he said he loved Lady Bird
so here's someone that it's not even
really you would think that wouldn't be
the audience right but he said and he
was recommending it to the people he was
with and we were kind of talking about
it so you can see how he somehow
resonated with that voice and I mean
it's a great scent the truthfulness of
that mother-daughter relationship which
wasn't pretty
you know how they got in each other's
faces and talked to each other but it's
was truthful and we know that they they
did love each other and you know so
touching towards latter part of the
movie when the mother who was really
kind of you know really tough with her
daughter and the daughter didn't feel
like she really loved her even liked her
and then we saw that she was trying to
write a letter to her and crumbled it up
like 30 times that's a that's another
form of love versus this would be the
boring
way of doing it and not so truthful to
the human experience would be well you
know I love you maybe I'm hard on you
but maybe I'm doing it for your own good
or maybe have my own issues so I'm not
really able to love that well versus the
simple beautiful act that she was
crumpling up letters because she want to
find the right words and couldn't that
says so much more than anything that's
on the nose and obvious writing the
whole part of coming from a smaller town
even though it's California's capital
but there is a a small-town feel to
Sacramento for anybody who's driven
through it and and wanting to like
really reinvent herself yes you know she
didn't want to go by her given name they
wanted to be a writer on the East Coast
right it wasn't okay to to be a writer
from California you know and and just
wanting to reinvent her and I think
everyone can identify with versus you
know no and so that's just really
wonderful writing versus I want to I
want to be a writer I'm tired of being
in the small town I want to reinvent
myself you know so that's that's what
although that's such a good example of
why you know some people say would they
get the feedback about not to write
expositionally what do you mean white
people can talk about like what you
don't like people to be direct sure
there's a time and place and sometimes
people are direct but most of the time
they're circling trying to figure out
their lives who they are and so on and
that was a very beautiful example of
that yeah I agree
so we've had a good two and a half three
hours here sometimes I'm in a time warp
when I do these interviews but we've
gotten incredibly valuable information
Wendy as we wrap up I would love to hear
a success story and if you could just do
us a favor maybe just leave out
identifying information that's kind of a
rule we have here sure I don't courage
okay so let's see I think well or a
couple one would be from something that
was quite a while ago that I had read a
a play by a writer and I was so enamored
of the story it was main and it was on
CBS and it was called it wound up being
called Sally Hemings an American scandal
and what I love about the story is that
she had written it and I had first found
out about it I think it was either seven
or nine years before it got made and all
say is that the stars were aligned and
it was the fact that what happened was I
came close to selling it within the
first two years so they had the project
it was under option I think when I was
at Hearst entertainment and came close
but didn't sell it and then one day the
writer and I read in the trades that
merchant ivory had a seldom movie called
Jefferson in Paris with Nick Nolte and
the two of us and this happens in the
business and it invariably I mean it
will happen stevarino I have two
projects actually where there are other
competing projects in the marketplace
and we're trying to get our stunt first
but anyway so the writer and I we were
quite despondent and then was like
alright life goes on and one foot friend
the other and you keep you know what's
the next project and you put your focus
there but I never forgot how much I
loved that script and so Merchant Ivory
movie was made and two years later I
felt like I would hear opportunities in
network television where they were
interested in doing they were doing
period pieces and you would haul me
which was a big producer at the time
doing lots of period films for Network
and so every couple of years I would
think maybe there's a different audience
that we could get and reach with them
you know TV and I would seek
opportunities and I would call up the
writer and I would say is that script
still available and she'd say yes and
one of those times seven years later she
said yes as a matter of fact
such-and-such actress I was having lunch
with her manager and we talked about and
she might be interested in playing the
role so I wanted calling up CBS and
saying we don't have a you know
commitment but we have preliminary
interest from so-and-so and she said
we'll send it over and it was originally
written as a two hour movie and the
network came back and said you know what
we think we might be interested in
turning it into a miniseries but instead
of making it so much about Thomas
Jefferson we'd like to make it more much
more Sally Hemings point of view so we
did we rolled up our sleeves we spent a
month working with her preparing an
outline to bring to the network so we
could show what the end of night one was
that would ensure people there was
enough of a cliffhanger that people
would come back for a night too so we
could justify yes this is enough
material for a miniseries and the day we
wind up going in to pitch two days
before it wound up hitting front page of
New York Times Wall Street Journal
iving Time magazine that they hadn't
done tests finally conclusively with
Thomas Jefferson and concluded from the
DNA that he in fact did have a long-term
relationship with Sally Hemings and that
they did have five children together so
all of our competitors were saying oh my
god you guys were so smart to be on it
and in the network two days after little
did they know that this was had started
about nine years earlier and as some
mature a lot of us have heard this
expression but it is a very good one
that success is when preparedness meets
opportunity
so if we didn't have though if I hadn't
fallen in love with this piece if the
writer hadn't written this wonderful
piece if in fact I I hadn't like
continued every two years to inquire and
see if there was a new opportunity then
you know it would and if we didn't do
our homework - really we spent a month
to go in and I've seen very good writers
who have blown deals when they don't
prepare enough you said something that
caught my ear and I just wanted to
follow up and that is you've seen
writers blow a deal because they weren't
prepared so are they not prepared to
know what the the genre that this
network is is used to dealing with
actually it's biting more with sometimes
if you have a script it can sell itself
but other times maybe you have a pitch I
mean I've seen very very like
established writers go in a room and
because they haven't prepared the pitch
really well and it kind of meanders and
it could be a really good story but it I
really am a big any advocate of
preparing and I reminded of seeing a lot
of people probably don't know Whoopi
Goldberg when she started out she was an
absolutely brilliant comedian and she
when I I saw her at a charity event and
man she killed it on stage and for her
to be there's no question that Genie
certain geniuses and comedy your great
ad libbing and this and that but they're
also for her to be and with most of the
great comics they look so spontaneous
they work their butts off rehearsing and
rehearsing to be able to deliver so
smoothly so I do think it's important
for you if you're going to be pitching a
project to to be prepared and that's
what we as producers had to do when we
were pitching the Sally Hemings piece
and it's what I do all the time and when
I'm working with writers and we're going
to go in and pitch is you know we have
to do the work why do you think an
established writer wouldn't prepare a
pitch like that I think maybe took for
granted or that had an attitude of well
I'll just wing it and these are people
who are very articulate but I also would
say the times have
we changed where I know like a former
boss of mine the network used to just go
to him and say why don't you do a
project about such-and-such topic and if
what now it just doesn't it just doesn't
work like that very established writers
need to also like even if you're I'm
sure and I can't speak for him but like
Ryan Murphy when he sells one of his
projects I'm sure that he has to at some
point tell the network what they're
gonna be seeing per our purse you know
the first hour the first night of a
miniseries we're going to be covering
such and such part of the OJ trial and
then I'm there you're going to talk
about your approach it's mostly so I
think that maybe taking for granted or
assuming well I'll just wing it or
ad-lib it but I think it's you need to
prepare and then the packaging again is
something you said people are looking at
so that means having talent attached
writing crew attached so for example
house of cars when it sold to Netflix
you had David Fincher one of the
preeminent contemporary directors who
hadn't yet done series that was really
attractive it was also material was
based on the book and a hit series in
the UK Kevin Spacey who was a big star
at the time was also attached so that's
like an ideal package a lot of the
marvelous mrs. Mazal that's the writing
team that did the gilmore girls which
was very successful in its original form
and then when it came back to Netflix
was also very successful so they knew
that they had proven entities with a
strong voice and who can deliver really
a successful show with really well drawn
character isn't situations consistently
so that's kind of like the sort of
there's some element that's
proven entity and/or really appealing it
could be someone who has just done a
movie at Sundance that garnered a lot of
attention and they come in and again
it's a thing about recognizing or that
someone has a strong voice and it's
harder to break into without you know
having that first like when if you've
already won some award at Sundance yes
it's easier to get Netflix attention but
how do you get that first award at
Sundance
it's because you have there's something
fresh in your material yeah and I
remember just a serious at HBO where
they wound up hiring completely
unestablished writers and trying to get
the name of the show but they had
written a play that wasn't even produced
but they fell in love with the writing
in their voice and then they the the
these that's writing team pitched the
series and it became like it had of I
think five seasons on HBO Wendy and
hearing what packaging means I think it
sounds great if you're established but
for a new writer is that something they
should even be worried about thinking
about striving for I think that again
the first thing a new writer should
concern themselves with is writing a
really really good script I do think and
I'm sure there are producers also who
you know come to film courage I feel
like when I hear a story so if someone
ever like a writers that I've been
working with who is also a documentary
filmmaker and he did a story and he
showed me a few clips and I was like oh
my god this is so moving this is this is
an amazing story and immediately I could
see that the character whose story this
was based on would be a great role to
attract a leading actor so immediately
I'm thinking
I'm thinking big names now that then
helps me sell it and promote it if I
like let's say call CAA and I say I
create a good compelling log line and I
say and it's a great vehicle for a
leading actor and they might include
some prototypes they go great send that
over because everybody is usually there
are exceptions but looking for something
that's going to attract a star whether
it's a female leaning actress or a male
leaning actor and I felt that this and
true stories very often it's a really
good source to attract a leading actor
so I think if I mean the first priority
is writing a good story I think with
screenwriters some and some
screenwriters so they know they
definitely think of a prototype when
they're writing it like they might here
was a renegade I see Marisa Tomei and
the role and that can help their process
I feel anyone who gets too attached to
the outcome before you've done the
process is probably not a good way to go
and the with in the cases that say more
with producers or if you're a writer and
you don't yet have a have a script on a
particular subject but you've optioned a
true story or maybe they've written an
article that appears in a magazine and
it can tell itself because there have
been stories option or turned into
movies from newspaper articles I think
boys don't cry mean we know it was a
true story the first time I became aware
of it I actually had read it in a
magazine and I wanted to option I tried
to get the rights and sell it and I was
not able to at the time I was primarily
focused on network and it was a little
too edgy for a regular network anyway
she but that that was did come from an
article as well as they said a true
story Argo was a true story also was an
article which I think may have been that
jumping-off point for the
it capturing the imagination of Cluny
anytime if you have something that's an
article and if it's a tree story and you
can it just it you can you can sell true
stories very often without having a
script yet so if you're a screenwriter
that is something to think about if
there's a true story that you like and
you might think oh gee this is a could
be a great vehicle for you know any
number of young actresses or offers a
great role for male lead in his 40s so I
think it's always wise to think about it
but not the cart before the horse where
that becomes necessary the dominant idea
I but in the case of let's say if the
writer producer has optioned the rights
to a true story then they would go out
and start trying to package so it would
be about trying to get it in the hands
of a production company that has greater
access and leverage and ability to reach
out to agents to attach an actor
director and so on the also they can try
to get to an agent I do coaching with
with those who are not represented to
help them get through the gatekeepers
and through certain bypass certain
industry protocols in order to get their
material seen there's ways that you can
pitch that can entice someone even if
you don't yet have an agent does that
answer the question about like packaging
yeah I think so yeah I would say
generally ideally you if you can get it
to a production company they are going
to be in a better position to try to
attach those key elements and so if
someone says well you know we don't take
unsolicited material right then doing it
through someone like you who could help
kind of procure that or also saying well
then
we do what did you say that Oh dad I'm
like they said we don't take unsolicited
material that they the writer/producer
you can say alright well can I sign a
submission release form can you send
that to me and then they should show it
to their entertainment attorney right a
lot of writers don't like to sign them
but it is an industry standard if you're
not represented and it's and that's why
you should have an attorney take a look
but it is it is fairly standard but I do
understand why it's a catch-22 right so
yeah because if they don't do it they
might not be able to submit their
project and I know for myself sometimes
I've had to do them and there's some
depending on the language that I won't
sign and others that I will and that's
where the attorney to review yeah you
can't just go online and also just for a
bit because I'm not an entertainment
area so I'm not telling someone oh you
know dude go do this definitively they
should go see an expert in that field
unless they're themselves very
experienced at reading those kinds of
documents but generally yes have an
entertainment attorney look